i am i said
that's a little nail diamond impression
to no one there
and no one heard at all not even the
chair
oh haha you can hear me now
[Music]
sarah welcome to the show it's nice to
finally see you likewise
and i thought we would start
with a
uh with a an unfinished story from my
perspective which came about when i had
kovid and i was isolating and i was
watching multiple episodes of comedians
in cars getting coffee and i watched
your episode where you had coffee with
jerry
and you were beginning to tell this
heartfelt story you said i went through
a terrible depression i remember my
stepfather says what does it feel like
and then jerry jumps in to say excuse me
to the wait staff can i get some half
and half
and you're like really
was it that much of an emergency and
then the edit cut to a different segment
of the conversation
so
i was wondering if it's possible for you
to finish the cliffhanger because i was
actually interested to hear the rest of
that i went through a terrible
depression i remember my stepfather
saying what does it feel like and then
you got cut off by the half and half
wow
yes i can tell you exactly and i you
know it's one of the few like very clear
memories i have
of that time
depression came over me when i was 13
like
i always say it's like as as fast as
getting the fl you ever get the flu and
from one moment to the next you just go
you feel fine and then you go oh
oh my god i have the flu it was like
that fast it's just like a cloud
covering the sun and all of a sudden
it's dark you know
and it was
you know it lasted for a few years and
it was the 80s and i was put on
xanax that's a crazy story and
ultimately was just given more and more
and more until i was
13 and taking
16 xanax a day four xanax four times a
day good lord
it just doesn't even seem possible it's
it's i mean it
can't be legal to be giving a child that
much
drugs and
my mom and my dad were kind of trying to
come up with solutions and fix
things and my stepdad was the only one
who just asked me what it felt like
and it was the first time i had to think
about what it felt like and i really
came up with the perfect description
which is
it felt just like i was homesick
but i was home
so there was no way to satiate it you
know there was nothing to hope for
there was no home to go to i was home
yeah
and that was where if we place you in
time where were you at the time
206 county road bedford new hampshire
new hampshire 1110. can you think of or
identify anything that led to that wave
crashing over you at that time is there
anything that you can point to that
acted as a trigger
you know i remember the moment it
happened what was happening i
you know i was a chronic bedwetter and
we had the eighth grade camping trip
which was a four day
camping trip up mount cardigan and i was
the student leader
and i cried the whole time
and i had diapers hidden in my sleeping
bag
and i just felt humiliated and homesick
and i um
nobody
caught me with the you know like that i
slipped
diapers in my sleeping bag so that i
wouldn't pee in my sleeping bag yeah i
mean i was 12 13. but i just was
painfully homesick and i and i just i
was
i never enjoyed a moment of it it was
terrible and i i probably would have
loved it anyway
it was humiliating and uh we come home
and i just want to go home and go into
bed and i've got my giant
backpack with all my stuff and
everyone's getting off the bus and my
mom picks me up
and
she was a photographer and and
she just
was taking pictures of me like a
paparazzi and i was begging her to stop
and it was just this very odd
combination of being
photographed and ignored at the same
time
and that's when it happened and there's
a picture of it i have a picture of the
moment depression took hold of me
it's kind of incredible that you have
that
locked in the amber in a way you have
that moment captured
and part of the reason i'm asking is i
do not have an a clear vision of when
the depressive episodes that i've
experienced started i know that it seems
to be congenital my dad has had extended
depressions for as long as i can
remember
i i don't know when
my experience of that started right in
retrospect it kind of seems like it was
ever present but
what i'd love to do is actually flash
forward to something i read in a piece
from a few years ago in the guardian
because i'm curious about
how this has
kind of lent itself to your life so i i
read that your mom always said to be
your own best friend and this was at the
very end of a guardian interview i
suppose and the paragraph reads as we
say our goodbyes
mary the dog trots off down the corridor
to pay some visits and silverman asks if
we can hug i mentioned that she seems
happy glowing in fact why this is going
to sound obnoxious but mom always said
be your own best friend and i really
really mastered that and it and it goes
on
could you just
elaborate on that because i think this
is one of my lifelong quests is to get
to that point i would love to hear you
just speak
more
to that and maybe just describe
how your mom instilled it and also how
you practiced it
if if that was something that you
explicitly practiced
i did i you know um
i kind of went from mana you know i was
serial monogamist
i mean i couldn't i wouldn't go out on a
date with a guy without at least putting
two years on like i just
think maybe out of politeness but there
was one relationship i just completely
lost myself i
my partner fell in love with this
independent woman and i became a
completely dependent
codependent
you know i got out of that relationship
so emotionally atrophied i forgot who i
was i forgot i remember i just kept
saying like i don't know how to be
and that was really scary for me and i
think from then on i really got very it
became really important to me to
be alone and enjoy that and i became
i loved it i would come home and go what
do you want to do tonight me you know
what i just thought like
i love hanging out with myself but i
also love television you know i i said
recently on my podcast
i had to kind of admit
i always say how much i love being alone
and i do
but i'm
constantly being kept company right i've
got the tv on i'm listening to howard
stern i've got i'm listening to
i guess when i listen to music i think
that's
it takes me to a new place that that
isn't just company but it's it is a a
conf
yeah i'm trying to use
you know i don't know i just i really i
did actually practice like i lived in
this apartment building for 14 years i
just moved into my first house
since growing up in new hampshire
and but i would walk in from the
apartment building and there were
mirrors
by the elevator and i'd make myself look
in the mirror and give myself a thumbs
up and
even though it's silly because it's
silly i guess it always made me laugh
you know it would make it just makes me
laugh so
it's nice to have kind of inside jokes
with yourself i also became very
comfortable
talking out loud
when i'm alone talk you know it's it's a
funny when you first try it as an
experiment you really have to like break
through a wall like it feels so odd and
now i'm so comfortable doing it now are
you talking to yourself or other
people the world in general i just talk
out loud i think i think just
creatively just as a human i'll be
saying my half of a conversation i'm
imagining or or talk through or just be
in conversation with myself you know i
mean i think when someone has a dog they
feel comfortable doing that but
essentially yeah totally that isn't
talking to yourself you're talking to
another living thing but
is it that you know remove the dog and
there's there isn't a big difference in
that conversation in there right and so
i got really comfortable talking alive
so much so that i
i've had boyfriends that are like what
and i'm like
no nothing i wasn't talking to you
but i'm talking to myself but i feel
like i get a lot out of that just
talking because we are always
have this kind of inner monologue going
on
do we i don't know i think we do
yeah i think so we're always thinking
something
i mean meditation is trying to clear
that out so we must be always you know
have something in our heads
was that something that you always had
that
feeling of
enjoyment or being at ease with yourself
and you just had to resurrect it after
getting lost in that relationship or was
it something that you were kind of
building from the ground up afterwards
my friends always made fun of me because
i i have the opposite of fomo
one of my best friends john
he loves telling the story that i was
living in west hollywood and all my
friends lived on the east side and i
just never saw them because i couldn't
even imagine getting in my car and going
to a bar to hang out i don't know why i
don't just i just i like staying home
i love watching tv it's you know listen
i'm it's not very intellectual but i
it's really my joy and there was a
birthday party for two really close
friends
not even a block away and i didn't make
it and he was just like you're
unbelievable but when i do go out i am
social and i love talking to people and
meeting new people and i am a people
person but i just really love
i love being alone and i i've had
friends especially now really
annoyed with me that i'm not
connecting with them and um
i feel busy because when i have free
time i want to
take a nap or watch tv or snuggle with
my dog and i love my friends and i i do
drop the ball
a lot
i have a lot of friends that say why is
it always me calling you and i feel
terrible because i love them and i think
of them and i i keep
track of them you know on uh social
media whatever this is
this is [ __ ] excuses but uh i'm
really not good at staying connected
makes me think of friend jason freed
talking about the opposite of fomo as
jomo the joy of missing out yes
that's great yes that's his take i mean
there's nothing better than someone
cancelling clowns for me i'm just like
surprise gift yeah so you mentioned
watching tv are there series that you
have re-watched
multiple times or watched multiple times
or if you had to is there anything that
jumps to mind is something that you
would absolutely replay
law and order is my
safe space
i just something about this soft core
murder
[Laughter]
kind of like commedia version of things
ripped from the headlines like not re
not true crime but
homicidal but approachable
yeah you know you know you don't really
see blood you know but it's and i i it's
all broadway actors you know playing
cops and lawyers and i love watching the
same actors playing different roles you
know and just
i just and it's just
what i think i think it comes from this
which is
when you're on the road
it's a constant
wherever you are you can find a law and
order and it
it's like my uh
what do they call it in the
my totem
you know the movie yeah it's totally
yeah yeah it's like a totem of some type
it's a constant you know it's something
i can always you know i used to bring
the same like plaid blanket that i'd
shove into my bag just so i could put it
over the hotel
blanket and just have like
something just consistent yeah something
that feels like home lawn order has just
always been that and now i'm
it's so funny like i'm discovering
i'm loving colombo
from the 70s and 80s the classic
oh it's so good and just bizarre and i i
tend to not watch comedies even though i
really should and when i do i'm glad i
did but i think as a comedian it feels
stressful that i don't go like oh this
would be relaxing you know either it's
i don't like it or i like it and i go oh
god i wish i wrote that but but i do end
up liking it and one show that's on that
i watch the whole first three seasons
twice through
and i'm waiting for the fourth season
and it's a comedy is what we do in the
shadows what we do in the shadows what
is it about oh my gosh
it's on fx it is
it looks like a reality show all right
because it's one of those like
mockumentary style
but it's about these three vampires
living together in a house in staten
island and it's very like kind of show
about nothing like just about everyday
life getting along but then they have
unbelievable
effects so to see that in a format
that's like reality tv yeah the contrast
is so
fascinating and it's just brilliant
that's amazing i didn't realize that i
knew that name sounded familiar and i
didn't realize that it was made into a
tv show because it started as the new
zealand mockumentary i knew that i
recognized this and they said
jermaine clement that's right yeah yeah
that was outstanding i had no idea that
it had been made into a television
series the movie is so great but i have
to say i love the series even more
there's just some the actors are
unbelievable and it just it brings me a
lot of joy it doesn't give me that
comedy stress for some reason i think
i'm growing out of it
when you say comedy stress what does
that mean like like you're
analyzing it as it plays out in front of
you because it's your craft what do you
mean by comedy stress i think so and i
think i've i've shed that a lot but i
think comedians
kind of go one of two ways either they
watch every you know like judd apatow
watches
everything
comedy that comes out podcast movie tv
he just
loves consuming he loves comedy yeah
it's like when you watch like a scorsese
film or a tarantino film where you go
like oh these movies are made by someone
who loves movies right i think jet is
like of that school then there are other
comedians and i
i'm not proud that i fall into this that
just they can't it's not relaxing to
watch comedy i get it it's relaxing to
watch a murder mystery or you know like
for me i like thrillers or murdery stuff
peaky blinders
stuff that's just not in my world
something that i can just get lost in
when you wrote your memoir bedwetter
stories of courage redemption and p
was there any part that you found
particularly
or very cathartic to put down on paper i
mean you've
lived so publicly shared so many stories
was there anything that just felt
different or freeing or cathartic when
you put it in the book
or the opposite extremely difficult to
kind of put down
well the first couple months of of stuff
i wrote i had to throw away because it
was
i was writing the way i thought
a writer should write
instead of just
the prose of how i talk you know like or
just
me
however that is using your voice the
first time i did fresh air with terry
gross i remember i was like
well terry you know um you know and then
i was just like who is this
you know i felt like i had to
i grew up with npr i wanted to have that
voice
so these moments where i found myself
trying to
do or be what i've seen before what is
normal or what you know and then i had
to just throw it out
and uh i was writing with such furrowed
brow wouldn't it you could see it
then just almost being an investigative
reporter in my life
interviewing my parents and and
seeing how those stories
their perspective on things were the
same and where they were different and
kind of be a detective in my own life to
be able to tell a story and realizing
stuff i never realized you know having
to deconstruct
i always thought oh god well you know
deconstructing comedy just ruins it but
it kind of doesn't it's interesting and
to me it's fascinating it's what i love
and writing that book made me realize
really see the trajectory of how i
became a comedian because
i had a dad who thought it was hilarious
to teach his three-year-old swears
and then i would yell those swears at
the market you know and uh
i just i remember the feeling of yelling
it out
and all these grown-ups
giving me this
wild approval despite themselves
and that feeling
i just became addicted i remember my
like arms itched with glee and of course
i chased that i chased it shock became
my
currency at three and four and five you
know
and it just made so much sense you know
looking at how i depended on that and
then after my first
special which was a a stand-up movie
actually i didn't get a special with
anyone but the guy from interscope was
like i'll make a move
and he and jesus's magic was my first
special it came out like a like a movie
and after that
i had to start over like that was my
first special so it was the best of
everything i had ever done right now i
had nothing
i had done it as a one like a one-woman
show
for a few years
and then it came out in like 2004 or
2005.
so i had been working with all that
material for so long
and
then i just kept doing it a little bit
after it came out yeah i just didn't
know what to do because i had a real
identity crisis and it was
it was a great moment of growth in a way
because i
people didn't want to see the same
material i had to write new material but
in order to do that i had to disappoint
audiences right i had to start over
and now people came to see me i wasn't
just
comedian number seven at the improv
lineup people were coming to see me but
i had to start over
but what they expected was to be shocked
and surprised
and i wanted to give them that
and
i didn't know how to do that because
they had an expectation of it now
what i had to realize was
comedy dies in the second guessing of
what your audience wants to see it was
never how i had started and now i found
myself in this place where i was like
well
if they're expecting to be surprised
they need to surprise them but then then
i'm giving them what they're expecting
and and i just had to stop
and i got very inspired by watching
chris rock who
does a special i mean he's such a pro he
goes out on the road he runs it runs it
runs it tweaks it you know all those
things
and then he starts at zero
and he goes to the comedy cellar or
wherever he goes and the
they bring him up and the audience goes
bananas
and he doesn't take on that pressure of
wanting to give them what they want to
see
you just what do i got you know
he brings it down to zero he
and he just he bums
and maybe one or two or three things
there's something there and he it's work
and you have to be brave enough
to eat a bowl of [ __ ] and try new stuff
and see where it goes and then some
stuff that bombs you cut and some stuff
that bombs you still believe in it
there's something here i like this it's
it could be just missing uh
a beat or an and or a you know an
article of a word or i'm setting it up
too much or i'm not setting it up enough
the point is
you have to be brave enough
to bomb again and start over even if
you're
famous even if people come to see you
and you know they're gonna be
disappointed because that that processes
you can't avoid it you can't
write a monologue at home and memorize
it it's just not how comedy works the
audience is half of it
i would have to imagine a toughness
that you develop through repetitions of
that
attempting to rise from the ashes like a
phoenix with zero just eating [ __ ]
sandwiches
over and over again i have read
and i actually don't know the details on
this kind of deliberately because if i
knew all the answers to the questions i
was going to ask that would be very
boring for me
i would love to hear a bit about your
saturday live experience because i've
read that that
helped you to become tougher and i don't
know if that's true and i also don't
know the details of what happened but
could you
perhaps just describe what your
experience was
i think what i meant was it really was
like a boot camp you know and
i remember going in
thinking
oh my gosh
i have this job where i can dream things
up
and then they're on television it didn't
necessarily go that way but
it was a great experience and i learned
so much and
you know it was still
very much a boys club you know to use
that old
and
there were not many women around and it
was just a very different time it was
about to really change but it hadn't yet
i did like it and i got along with
everyone and i really shined
on thursday nights for punch-up that was
like where i could really what is
punch-up oh so thursday night
you take the the writer's room you sit
around a big table i mean this is how it
was in 94. and you go through all of the
scripts that are now chosen to be on the
show and we you punch them up you know
oh there could be a joke here let's
figure there maybe there's something
better for this just go through it and
see try to make it better as a group yep
and boy i mean it was there was
computers then but
they were
we still wrote on legal pads and gave it
to a room of typists
i remember my first day
i was put with these three
guys who were hired right out of harvard
and we were all 22.
but i didn't go to college i was a
stand-up you know and
and they kind of put us together because
we were the kids and the newbies or
whatever and um
i spent the whole day with these guys
and at the end of it they
i mean they thought i was a type they
just assumed i was a typist
at the end of the day you know we're
hanging out we're getting to know each
other and they go so were you a typist
or and i was like what i'm a writer like
you and it was just
you know i always think of
how it was for me to be a woman in
comedy
as how it was for me to be a woman in
basketball because
i played basketball growing up but not
at school i played at the y
and so i always played with
almost all men
and i still although i haven't played
since
march 2020
play pickup games with almost all men
sometimes a woman will play and it's
great and i always demand that we're on
the same team because i hate how they
always go well you will need to take a
girl you know like yeah i've played my
whole life i play you know but that
feeling of going to pick up games and
the
you can feel guys rolling their eyes or
a burden they feel that they have a girl
on their team or this and having to
prove yourself so much and i i like
using this analogy with other women in
comedy or other women that i play
basketball with or
you know
every every shot
as a woman that you shoot and miss
is like missing a hundred baskets
because you feel the weight of the guy
going
and maybe i'm putting that on them you
know it's not for maybe it's true and
maybe i'm putting it on them and either
way it shouldn't be in my head but it is
and you carry this weight and it doesn't
help you and i always say sometimes
especially in new york i love just
watching the pickup games and stuff
and there's always maybe there's a woman
playing and i go
watch how many times these guys shoot
and miss and shake it off and shoot
again and shoot again and shoot a cab
that's how you get better you you cannot
take on this
oh i'm a woman in a guy's game and i
you know that that feeling that if i
shoot and miss
i better not shoot for a while i better
just work on setting pics and it really
taught me something suddenly
taking
the focus off of myself which is really
like
a self-centeredness
and watching the guys and watching them
fail shake it off shoot again shoot
again
and go oh yeah
yeah i can keep shooting if i have a
shot i should shoot
does that make sense at all as an
analogy it does make sense it does make
sense
my understanding with the with the snl
oh god i completely forgot where you
were no
that's okay no that's okay because i
think it ties to the basketball
is it true that you got fired by fax
or let go by fax
i got a call
a three-way call from my agent my
manager and i it never occurred to me
that i wasn't coming back i was already
writing sketches i was like and uh this
year is going to be better it's going to
be great you know and
and i go oh they're both calling me
hello you know what wonderful news must
this be and of course i was fired and
they said that they had gotten a fax
they had gotten the facts it's fine that
they got a fact that's the business
that's how it was and they let go of a
lot of people that were had their first
year that year yeah but i remember
starting out comedy and guy comics
giving me advice and
they go um the best woman comic is paula
poundstone and that was probably true i
love her but they go and the reason is
because
a guy could do the same material and it
would work
and i bought it
i bought that i mean looking back i'm
just like that's so absurd
that a woman comic couldn't talk about
the experience of being a woman
well the conceit was yes the audience is
half men and half women but the women
are in dates and they only laugh if the
man laughs so your audience is the men
ah
i never thought about that well it's
absurd and stupid yeah
that was what it was you mentioned
not taking on this
this burden of
for lack of a better term kind of hiding
say as a woman
taking a shot in a basketball game if
you happen to miss right
in in the case of snl
because part of what's impressed me does
impress me still about you is just your
longevity in the craft i mean it's it's
it's really no it's remarkable it's
really remarkable and it's not
altogether common at all
and i'm curious after the snl were you
able to dust yourself off and just get
right back to work quickly did it take a
while to recover from yes
all right please tell me more
i have a a polaroid picture i took of
myself and i saw it when i was moving
you know
and it's i had cut my bangs like
maybe an inch just insane looking bangs
and it just says no confidence
on it i wrote
and i just i remember thinking like
am i in show business any like i i
didn't know
where i fit in i didn't know who i was i
didn't know how to just you know and
eventually i just put my head down and
kept doing stand up and it it led me
wherever it led me i've really never
made a plan
in
show business i've never thought like i
want to do this or i
i know this is maybe not
you know it's not advice at all but i
i've never set goals for myself
i just always kind of
i don't know
i i love the stuff i do i think of
myself as i do odd jobs and like when i
couldn't do stand-up i
said well i was i have to do a podcast
i'm what am i going to do with all of
this you know yeah but i do think part
of the longevity is just being open to
be changed and
what i learned after that first special
that i talked about that
really changed my life along with
therapy great therapy but
to be brave enough to bomb to
change and no longer have the same fans
to disappoint people
and just go on the trajectory
i go on you know um there's a line in a
song and a musical
sunday in the park with george it's a
song called move on and she says
the choice may be mistaken the choosing
is not you've got to move on and it it
does free you i feel like you can
thinking of that it's the whole
play is quite brilliant it's about art
you know and life
but it doesn't matter the choice
it does it doesn't make a difference
you're gonna wind up where you're gonna
wind up but make one you know right
because it can be so paralyzing i think
totally not wanting to make a mistake
and and i think
what i learned from that basketball
analogy as well
along with a brilliant quote by charlie
kaufman and it's being talked about a
lot just in general is
how essential failure is
and what you do with it
which is not a new concept anymore is
this it i'm just pulled it up failure is
a badge of honor it means you've risked
failure if you don't risk failure you're
never going to do anything that's
different than what you've already done
or what someone else has done oh well i
never heard the whole thing all i knew
is don't fear failure failure should be
a badge of honor it means you risked
failure
you know and and look at all these you
know the the concept of cancel culture
and i can argue either side of it
passionately but
another thing is if you think of
yourself as a risk taker in comedy for
instance
the thing that makes it a risk
is that there's something to lose is
that there's consequences yes totally
you can't just say i'm risky and then be
angry if there are any consequences
you gotta take it
yeah
and be changed by it or disagree with it
maybe but wonder about it it's like when
you get notes from a network and i know
there must be a i know this sounds very
specific to
show business but of course any job
where you have a boss
when you get notes from a network and
you go this is stupid this is not even
there's always something
that they're on to some germ of
something the spirit of that note that
you need to figure out because they're
on to something but they maybe don't
know how to articulate it
the first sentence in that quote by
charlie kaufman that i don't have any
context for was do not simplify and then
it goes on to do not fear failure and i
wonder what that refers to that's an
interesting sense we need to find the
whole thing
so i'll put it in the show now
inspirational writing advice from
charlie kaufman it's on youtube we're
gonna have to watch it
i heard it as a quote or i read it as a
poet i was like oh my god and completely
attached myself to it and of course i
never just googled the whole thing which
[Music]
now i'm very excited to watch
yeah it's 41 minutes we'll link to that
and
ah charlie kaufman's got all sorts of
good quotes say who you are release it
in your life and in your work tell
someone out there who is lost someone
not yet or on someone who won't be born
for 500 years your writing will be a
record of your time it can't help but be
that but more importantly if you're
honest about who you are you'll help
that person be less lonely in their
world because that person will recognize
him or herself in you and that will give
them hope all right charlie kaufman i'm
sold
charlie kaufman who was as i understand
it
one of modern cinema's most celebrated
writers with work including surreal
fantasy being john malkovich cerebral
sci-fi eternal sunshine of the spotless
mind
comedy drama adaptation and
extraordinary animation
ano malissa animal lisa oh yeah
wow all right well we will
put that video inspirational writing
advice from charlie kaufman 41 minutes
in the show notes
have spent way too much time on the
internet with this
kind of accidental audience or
unexpected audience after my first book
in 2007 and i've seen in the last say
four or five years
some really
disconcerting patterns emerge just
watching this this large i mean for me
in a large-ish following
massive
i've seen
a lot of well-intentioned in you know in
some cases well-educated doesn't really
matter but thoughtful people get pushed
to the polar ends
into these extremes or pushed themselves
or just been led by algorithms who knows
right you know it makes me think of and
i could also be getting the facts wrong
on this but it was either fahrenheit 451
or 1984 one of those lovely dystopian
novels
that
makes me think of the book burning in
one of them but probably fahrenheit 451
and there's this kind of monolithic
state and the firemen and so on but the
book burning started with the people the
people themselves burning the books and
the kind of righteousness porn and
reputational assassination that i've
seen
even among people who
would you would think to be at the same
kind of tribe let's just say listeners
of this podcast is really disconcerting
to me and i'm curious to know
where you think this goes like does it
burn itself out in some fashion does it
get
increasingly bad with higher and higher
consequences
because you're watching a lot of these
these events unfold and you're noticing
them
if you had to hazard a guess where do
you think this goes right three years
from now two or three years or four or
five years from now what do you think
what do you think it looks like
i'm gonna have to say a very solid i
don't know
i couldn't begin to guess what the
future holds for us in terms of
this yeah i think the sooner people
realize we're all totally connected and
you're fighting with yourself basically
yeah the better
but i do think there's we're at really
like the pendulum is has frozen in both
extremes yeah
and they're almost a mirror image of
each other in a real [ __ ] up way as
much as
neither side
would want to
see that yeah but i don't know i don't
know how to what is your answer to that
i mean listen you
when you leave social media for a while
you realize it's not the whole world
it's not even
most of the world or half of the brand's
a very small part of the world
yeah but it's given us this thing where
we in real time can see how like almost
everyone you know it's what seems like
everyone feels and it's
it can
yeah i don't know i don't know where
it's gonna go from here
facebook and youtube
radicalize people by
by algorithm
you know it's not like they're set up to
do it but
greed has
made them do it because it
inciting rage is they found very
lucrative yeah twitter too and twitter
and so you see a headline
and the headline is designed even
reputable places now their headline is
clickbait it's it's so
one small piece of a story that is the
most
salacious
yeah and maybe if you click on and read
it proves to not be true at all or is
wildly minimal to
but who clicks on it and reads it very
few people they're reacting to so it's
just these
these little
beams of light coming out at your face
to
upset you
and make you angry
and whether you're whoever you are
it's designed just for you yeah this uh
you know a guest on the podcast very
bright guy
who has the most endurance of any guest
i've ever had balaji srinivasan he talks
about
the media you consume having root access
to your brain in the same way that you
can have root access to
a computer and therefore control the
computer right so if you if coding is
scripting
the behavior let's just call it behavior
of computers
then
media is basically the code that gets
installed into humans and so when you
have algorithms on twitter
or anywhere else for that matter youtube
right that
are
kind of self-perpetuating
by reinforcing to greater and greater
extremes because they're more effective
for producing clicks
of course i'm you know i'm not a
nostradamus i don't know where that
leads but i do see
you know more and more examples of the
kind of hatred and vitriol online
resulting in people getting doxxed it's
like right so having their physical
addresses and personal information
posted
in the hopes that there will be some
type of
uh
violent consequence and
and i think it's also just my nature i
come from a long line of warriors so i
think that it's it's i have to be aware
of my predisposition to go
to worst case scenarios
i don't know there's some part of me
that maybe perversely just
get something out of imagining these i
think for a lot of people and i think
myself included and i really see it like
in my stepmom and
and so many of us that worry is
even though we don't want to be in worry
we don't want to be worried it's our
comfort zone because it's familiar
do you experience that yourself or do
you do you see that more so and yeah i
do i do
i mean all these things i know and talk
about is
purely aspirational for me you know
oh i can hear myself
talking i mean my mouth
well i mean in a sense they're
aspirational but i'm still impressed by
this
sort of success story around the be your
own best friend i think that's very
rare i think that at least in
you know my kind of concentric circle of
friends i think that particularly if
people are driven and i think even
though you may not have a five or
10-year or 20-year plan i mean i think
most people would consider you're very
successful at what you do
a lot of that
drive seems to translate to people being
very dissatisfied with themselves or
hypercritical of themselves or at least
they seem to correlate so
i mean what advice would you give
somebody who's
maybe prone to
self-flagellating would you have any
advice to them if they're just they're
not yet at a place where they maybe they
maybe they don't even particularly like
themselves right but they use work as a
way to occupy their minds so that
they're distracted from that i think in
terms of the self flagellation i see it
and i
i don't mean this to add to pile on
someone who is
constantly putting themselves down in
their head or out loud
but it is
not
modesty
it is
self-obsession unless those thoughts
turn into change
that make you into the person you would
be very happy to be
then it's very masturbatory it's you're
not seeing there's no room to observe
and watch and be delighted and amused by
others it's it's just all self yeah and
listen i have friends that are comics
that
cannot be alone they are out until four
in the morning and only go home when
it's they can drop to sleep
and
it worries me some of my friends why do
you think they do that because being
alone is terrifying for them
being
still
being alone being alone with their
thoughts
is terrifying and listen i admit to you
i i love being alone but alone with my
thoughts is a whole other thing i mean i
i am often but i still constantly
entertain myself with
television and radio and radio
i just think when you accept yourself
the way you accept any schmuck on the
street you just have a lot more room for
other stuff
you know i had a therapist who said look
in the mirrorless
and i found it to be incredibly profound
yeah just know that any one of us
looking the mirror does not see what
other people see
not that what other people see is what's
important but we cognitively distort
what we see
in the mirror so much i mean look at
the whole thing with selfies and and i
see it
the same as people who heckle and i know
that sounds really weird connection
what hecklers to me whether they're
saying yelling something out lovely or
mean or whatever it is it's interrupting
you know like a show yeah
and the same with people who are all
constantly taking selfies i feel like
the subtext is the same for both which
is i exist right
and you know that's ultimately what it
is life is this existential crisis of
like what is it to exist and it we need
it to mean something
yeah i i completely agree with you on
the
and i say this as someone who i think is
pretty self-absorbed as evidenced by my
sort of depressive episodes in in the
past
no but because it is the the sort of the
me me i i
song right when you're
either
suffering from depression or anxiety
you're kind of trapped in a
self-referential loop right so i think
yeah it's not conceited it's not you
know it's awful but it's to be consumed
yeah and i think that what's been hard
for me is realizing that but not being
able to extricate myself from that loop
right so
this this might be
a good time to just ask
in what ways therapy has been most
helpful to you
so there's good the bad and the ugly
among therapists right so i'm yes i'm
wondering
how has therapy
most helped you or why has it been
helpful
besides that it's
another perspective
on your life you know like you know and
uh and how you see things and how you
relate to people
listen there are plenty of terrible
therapists out there but it's always
bizarre to me that
people will drive 10 different cars to
see which one they like best or what you
know and
you know if you're lucky enough to be
able to afford therapy and it's becoming
at once less and less accessible and
more and more accessible because there's
a lot of stuff online and there's a lot
of stuff i mean
the best therapist i ever had
charged a hundred dollars a session this
is recent you know up until very
recently
but i mean that's not nothing but it's
for therapy it's pretty good but it's
become more and more accessible and i
just think
find the right you know if you have the
luxury to be able to find the right one
for you do that but i i found the right
one for me
and he
just changed my perspective in a lot of
ways and i you want some greatest hits
yeah definitely sounds like you have a
couple locked and loaded so let's do it
i've one he said have you ever predicted
anything that's happened in your life
you go well
yeah you know i guess not because we're
looking through a pinhole
you don't know what's coming up next
we have a fear of
the unknown
that's why we tend to and i'm very
ritualistic and i it's hard to get me to
try new things actually and
and i try to break out of that but we
have a fear of the unknown
we
have a fear of change
but like the truth is you should be just
on the edge of your seat what's gonna be
next you know i don't know we're looking
through a pinhole we don't know what's
coming up next i like that
he changed
my perspective in a lot of ways and i
realized like
listen i
i see this when i think about when i
went into depression so fast
and i think about it in beautiful
wonderful ways that as well but i mean
you change your perspective by one
degree
and the whole room looks different
the whole world looks different yeah and
that's neat to me
when you've been in the sweet spot
whatever that means from a therapy
perspective
how
often are you doing sessions is it once
a week twice a week
once every two weeks what is your
cadence
i'm very
erratic with it i'll i'll go once a week
if i'm working through something and
sometimes i'll go like months or a month
or something and be like you know what i
need to talk this out or
i've gone for many years regularly and i
i kind of go
i'm starting actually with a new
therapist i was in my second session on
wednesday
why are you starting with the new
therapist if you had a great therapist
he's so wonderful well
i could just say he's retiring but i
actually left a little before he retired
and i love him so much
but
and talk about pathway to i'm not giving
him a path to redemption or would i he
doesn't need to be redeemed i just
we had a session after i lost my friend
to covet that i was my writing partner
on this
musical
and the music part and i had my first
session with him since spending three
months in new york
during the first three months of the
pandemic
and uh i told him the whole story of of
losing adam and and just seemed it was
also you know he texted me oh my god i
think i have this thing you know and
then like oh my i'm still sick i can't
get a test anywhere this is crazy i have
like a really high fever you know and
then
and then not getting any more texts and
he was in the hospital i'm in the then i
get a text i'm in the hospital with
kobet you know and then the tech stopped
and then his girlfriend was reaching out
to us and then he was gone i mean
because it was so early they put on a
ventilator and it was
anyway um i tell them the whole story
and i guess i don't have to
not say this because it's my therapy
it's you know i mean i feel like but um
he was like
well what did it say on his death
certificate because they're calling
everything copic now you know because
they pay
hospitals thirty thousand dollars to
call something and like he's like a
covent denier
and i don't care what he is but he
didn't need to bring it there and i was
pretty positive the thing to say was
are you okay
you know
yeah gee
i'm so sorry and now i feel like someone
online who he didn't say exactly what i
needed him to say and now i'm angry at
him i'm not angry at him i love him i'm
so grateful for him but i just needed to
uh
detach with love you know
and i have a very close friend who who
also knows him and said just you know
talk to him about it or whatever and for
some reason i just don't feel i don't
feel angry about it i just don't
i just want to kind of move on i had
such wonderful years with him and i
don't need him to say so you know well
listen he's on his own thing and i'm so
grateful for what he taught me but i
just kind of moved on
like you can get a lot from someone and
a lot of value and they can do something
you really disagree with yeah the latter
does not necessarily negate the former
which is hard to sometimes see out there
on social media yeah it's uh it's odd
that we
seem to be living in a world where
people just expect you to
they're just if you
say something that wasn't what in their
mind what you should say
they're just so disappointed and i you
know i've always maintained like
personally i go hey i'm not everyone's
cup of tea and it's okay if you don't
like what i say and it's okay if you're
not no longer a fan
yeah i had the author and i mean she's
just an incredible historian and
historical thinker doris kearns goodwin
on the podcast and
i asked her if she thought
leaders like say an abraham lincoln or
an fdr
or a churchill could exist could
actually be elected in today's day and
age and she said no because the veneer
of perfection has to be
the facade has to be presented in such a
way
that
you know if any of the kind of foibles
and flaws of many of these leaders had
been transparent or were transparent in
today's day and age there's no way they
would get elected even though in other
respects are really effective so it's
definitely
i don't know why today is the day i've
decided to showcase all my dystopian
concerns about the next five to ten
years i bring it out in people
now the sarah silverman podcast
i think you alluded to at least one of
the reasons perhaps that you began the
podcast but why did you decide to start
the podcast
the pandemic happened and i couldn't do
stand-up and i just felt
like
this is i have
where do i put all this and uh just made
sense to do a podcast i've been
resisting doing a podcast for so long
and why'd you been resisting it because
like everyone was doing it i wasn't an
og like you you know
but um i really liked the idea of being
able to talk to
to hear from people
all over and i i'm shocked by the people
who call from so many other countries i
didn't even it occurred to me that this
is just so
so american you know it didn't occur to
me that this would go to other countries
you know i just crossed my mind
so that's been really neat but just that
people from all over are really calling
in and it was i was hoping that would
happen and um
you know there there it's voicemails
every once in a while i go i need to
talk to this person more and we'll call
but it's mostly voicemails and but
people will call in and follow up
and i've become kind of connected to
this
kind of community but it's always
changing and um
i really i love the it's so different
from my stand-up first of all like
sometimes i
listen back to the podcast they go
i there's no evidence of a comedian like
who do i think i am like i you know but
then
i don't know i i try to remember joy
before i go on i go
stop taking yourself
it's so it once i i take a little puff
at night and then if i listen to some
podcasts i go who the [ __ ] do you think
you are it's like embarrassing to me but
then i go back and do it again and
people call in with questions and i
really feel like i can help or at least
say what i'm thinking you know
it's morphed into this thing that i i
didn't expect and i didn't really know
what it would be but i knew i just
wanted to talk
and hear people's thoughts and opinions
and then let that be the trajectory of
the episode
and it's been really fun how do you
choose which to speak to because you use
i was looking at your your twitter feed
you have an enormous
new york city plus size twitter
following like 12
12 point something million and you use
speak pipe
but with that sized audience you must
get an absolute avalanche of
different voice messages how do you
choose what to respond to
i've got two producers on the show raj
and diana and they go through all of
them and they bring me about 20.
we listen to them the night before like
tonight because i record on tuesdays and
it comes out on thursday but it you know
and i just go oh yeah that's good you
know i kind of talked through like what
i might say and i just yeah yeah let's
do that one and i pick i probably pick
like 18 of the 20 you know and
then
that night or the next morning i'll kind
of
think about it more and make like an
outline and just to have thoughts in my
head and then we record and
sometimes i
respond the way i planned and sometimes
i don't at all i go a different
direction but
and uh
we i always record way more than we need
and so we either throw stuff away or if
it's evergreen you know could be used
another week it's not about like the
news of the this week or something we
might save it
because then i'm i when i work on the
play in march
march april may
i'll probably be able to do some
episodes in new york but uh
i like to ha you know stockpile some
that are
brand new but are could be any could be
a month from now or
so um and maybe you didn't want those
exact details but that's how it
basically how it goes are you kidding i
love exact details yeah all right who am
i talking to i stockpile exact details
so you're in good shape it's interesting
because with my stand up i'm a very slow
honer i'll work on a joke for
months months months months maybe even a
year after year and and i i hone it so
slowly even though it may sound kind of
in the moment you know i'm i'm working
on it inch by inch and on the podcast
it's very immediate it's messy i'm
loving now being able to now that i can
do stand up more and more less and less
and more and more depending
they're very different you know and it's
i i like doing odd jobs i like doing
different stuff and when they converge
it's kind of neat where if i say
something i go oh that could maybe be a
joke you know but has anything
from the podcast
popped in an unusual way for you where
one topic or one episode
unexpectedly
got particular traction has has anything
been really surprising for you overall
yeah i'm always surprised well you know
at first i was like
you know i i usually i pick like three
little clips to
post on social media
yeah and
do we go with what works best or do we
go with you know it's it's because it's
a quandary because then you become
you run into the same problem with
second guessing the audience on stage
right so this is yeah i want to dig into
this because this is an important choice
right like do you use what you think is
going to get kind of the cheap applause
so to speak or like the easy layup or
do you use something else so how do you
make that but the irony is and i don't
know if there's irony but
i would
post those clips that i thought were
funny
and
and we're like
and then like i post something that i go
like oh this is like
opinionated thinky
hippy dippy granola you know stuff that
is also me but
and um
people
really responded to the more serious
stuff
there's some a couple communities that
have become like motivational speakers
and
it's you know i
i find it incredibly obnoxious and then
i'm like
how am i different am i doing that you
know but i and i think maybe that's why
because people always go why do you
always say you're talking out of your
ass or whatever i go because i am
i'm this is me in process trying to make
sense of life
and
so my answers there there's no authority
in my answers other than
exp my own life experience and and and
having not died
i've lived all long while i hope to keep
living a while and i
have learned a bunch of stuff
but uh
it's a fine line and that i would be
horrified if i
saw that i was had become that and i
really spot when people qualify things a
lot and now i'm doing it right now and i
do it on my show sometimes where i go oh
i don't know i'm talking out of my ass
what do i know but i i feel like it
needs that qualifier just to prevent me
feeling like i think i know best you
know yeah but my mother was like that
she and i've become my mother you know
she she couldn't help but i mean there
were not enough comments cards in the
world for my mother she had she felt she
could correct so many things and just in
the strangers around her or like i mean
it was almost like a horror movie like
you could pick up a book
there was a book she had that was like a
guide to santa barbara
and it had like in pen corrections all
throughout it like grammar any you know
she
but now i've found that i've become that
person that i'm like i'm helping like
she would always go i'm helping you know
and i would go oh
but you know i was at like 7 11 and a
kid you know 19 year old kid or
something was buying like orange soda
and doritos and i just couldn't
control myself and i was like really my
almonds are the same price
this is what you're feeding your body
you know i'm just like oh my god sarah
i'm helping i'm helping i would love to
ask you
there are there are a few questions i'll
tell you what i'll give you a twofer and
you can pick which one you want to
answer first okay so the first is how
you chose to
become involved with i smile back
and the other is
what
you learned or any kind of lessons taken
away from gary shandling
oh
i'll just do both of them in order yeah
i smile back
was there's a book written by amy
koppelman and she
had sent it to my agent at the time
who's a real character do you ever want
to interview an agent
i don't know why you would want to but
he's fascinating michael kevis
and he sent it to me and he said she
wants you to
play this part and i was like she does
and i read it and and it was really
interesting and then she she and her
friend paige
dylan wrote the screenplay and then they
were very
i
i said i'd do it and they were really
collaborative and we
worked on a lot of it together and it
was very hard i mean you know i remember
thinking
yeah this is a really heavy movie
but it doesn't mean it's not going to be
fun like yeah i'll act that it's the
reality of the moment and then they'll
say cut and we'll have you know be fun
and it was i it was a good experience
but it was so i didn't know that
you know you have to have your
thousand hundred thousand hours in
tom hanks seems like he can just you
know i always heard he jokes around and
he's you know we'll eat he's like the
the belle of the plato he's like funny
and all this and then they say action
and he's captain phillips right i don't
have the experience to be able to access
everything like once i access those kind
of things they're just on my lap you
know so it was
i remember a friend would call and say
how's it going i go it's
i don't this is really
a bummer you know like it i just i
wasn't able to
just separate so it was just a lot
mentalized but i'm so glad i did it and
it was an incredible experience and um
that movie's really relentless though
yeah even precious had moments of relief
you know i just go yeah this movie is
just like
too much but but i it was really fun to
do and and and amy koppelman just
directed her next book that was made
into movies which is really cool anyway
so that was that well i just want to say
two things real quick so the first is
i thought you did an outstanding job i i
think a lot of folks have exposure
to
your comedy of course and you as comic
and
so on but less exposure to you
in a dramatic capacity and i thought you
did a really outstanding job and a
really nuanced job so i wanted to say
that and i've
had dinner with amy before she is a very
smart
very
observant
fascinating
woman so i wanted to
to also encourage people to check out
our work yeah
gary shanley gary shandling
what did i learn from him he you know i
can't say enough about him and really if
anyone's
any for anyone who's listening please
watch judd apatow's
two-part documentary on him is is it the
zen diaries of gary is that the yeah
oh it's so good and and but gary was
so generous and so
he
we played basketball at his house every
sunday and there were
star you know big celebrities that
played there were you know writer's
assistants pas that plagued you it
didn't matter he he assembled this
ragtag group you know and they were all
his friends equally there are ncis
scripts
that have benefited from you know that a
writer would show
to gary and he'd give you know
he he
he put so much into
helping writers helping
actors everything he learned the hard
way he really offered up to us on a
silver platter
and some things you got to learn the
hard way but so many things i learned
about
silence about
taking you know that in stand up even
just the the moments in between the
words
and
the currency in that you know currency
sounds like a you know or the the
specialness or that that
you're saying something in those moments
just as well and and to not be afraid of
them to not feel like you need to fill
that empty space
and it's interesting learning that for
stand-up but then in life you know i
hear my dad when we talk on the phone
now we facetime and it's different but
when we talk on the phone
and there would be like a dip
in conversation he'd go um uh uh uh um
um
uh like
that fear
of
silence or you know is is so
real in people yeah i learned that from
him it's very interesting and he was a
studied buddhism he was a buddhist he
was he but it wasn't because he was
naturally that way
because he was riddled and he needed it
and that's all of us right yeah
and trying to just be honest and get to
the core of you know he kept a journal
which you know i think your comedy
notebook is half journal and he would
say just be gary shamling whatever that
is on stage you know or like all these
things and and judd
helped clean out his house and stuff and
and would post pictures of a lot of his
journal pages that are
i don't think he would be upset about it
were so
revealing and so helpful
he wasn't perfect
but he was in search of you know and and
just even learning that or watching that
in him was so
fortifying and helpful
here's a just a
question that is sometimes directly
leading to a dead end but that that's on
me so i'll try it
just be gary chandling made me think of
this so
if you could put a message
any message could be a quote could be an
image could be anything really
on a
billboard metaphorically speaking just
to get it out to
hundreds of millions billions of people
what might you put on that billboard
two things come to mind
one is
the story about
fred phelps who started the westboro
baptist church
i don't know this story
oh oh so he started the west bro baptist
church i'm
you've got to interview megan phelps
roper
grew
did
in the westboro baptist church and her
story is
amazing she's
amazing
her change and the ways in which she
didn't change that she was always this
beautiful person but
to grow up in something and believe it
with your whole heart and and anyway her
story is incredible
fred phelps her grandfather started the
westboro baptist church and of course
these are the people that show up to
funerals with signs that say god hates
[ __ ] and yeah they're those people
and
people showed up at his funeral
with signs
that said
sorry for your loss.
and i just thought that was the most
beautiful
act of
protest i've ever heard
so and and for some reason
i feel like
that on a billboard
would would be
useful for everyone in some way i don't
want to chew up too much your time sarah
i'm having a great time is there
anything else that you would like to
talk about is there anything else that
you would like to
comment on
any suggestions you'd like to make
anything you'd like to point people's
attention to that comes to mind i'll say
what my auntie martha told me grab joy
where you can get it
grab joy where you find it i was
i was
single and i was in dc and i was
supposed to go to la for home to la for
a friend's
memorial service
comedians killed themselves a lot
and
i kind of wanted to go back to new york
to see this guy i was dating and i feel
guilty i
she goes go to new york
grab joy where you can get it your
friend is gone you can
honor him in your mind you know what i
mean other ways
grab joy where you can get it although
comedian memorials are really fun
okay i can't let that sit so tell me
more
what makes them fun well because you're
i find funerals to be pretty fun usually
i mean you know even if you're sobbing
right you're with a group of people that
loved this person
talking about the greatest hits of
who they were and how they impacted
everyone and uh with comedians i mean
i mean
gary's gary shanley's memorial was
amazing
you're laughing and crying kevin neeland
for lack of a better word closed
the show
the memorial and
he was sobbing and he was killing i mean
and it was just all real and true
afterwards when everyone goes their
separate ways and lives life is when you
grief punches you in the face you know
when you're out lying at ralph's you
know two weeks later but
but you're just hearing the funniest
stories and the greatest things they
wrote and said and and it's
it is a celebration i think that's a you
know
uh sarah kate silverman where's the kate
from
i don't know i i think i was i was
supposed to be named kate
sarah silverman and my nana said
no i know someone named kate and she's i
don't like her or something so they go
well we'll say sarah kate
that's the amazing story of my uh if i
was boy if i was a boy i know i was
going to be
john robert after the kennedys
wow yeah robert
i think sarah kate works i like it yeah
sarah kate silverman at
k silverman on twitter
thank you so much for taking the time
people should absolutely check out the
sarah silverman podcast
where each week you can
find joy where you can get it one
bite-sized audio morsel at a time yeah
and
your book your first book memoir is the
bedwetter stories of courage redemption
and pee oh yeah that's from 2010. it is
from 2010
the musical the musical is called the
bedwetter and it comes out previews
start in april at the atlantic theatre
new york and that is
based on the book but it's just the
year i was 10. and i'm not in it there's
a little little pint-sized incredible me
i mean the actresses get incredible
well congratulations i know that's been
a long time in the making i know that
your dad has been counting down the days
as uh as best i can tell yes yes he was
like how much longer do i need to stay
alive
and it's here it's here in in just a few
months fingers crossed
and
thank you so much for taking the time
sarah i really enjoyed the conversation
and getting to know you not just through
doing the homework and the research for
the conversation but having the
conversation itself
and
i hope that we get to have another
conversation sometime me too
and for everybody listening we will put
links to everything in the show notes
and you can find that at tim dot blog
podcast and until next time thank you
for tuning in bye
you